inició en Egipto la copa 27 de la Cumbre
climática de Naciones Unidas
representantes de más de 130 países
participan en el encuentro que comenzó
con la aprobación de un fondo de daños y
pérdidas para indemnizar a las víctimas
del calentamiento global tendremos
reporte de nuestra enviada especial un
avión de pasajeros estrelló este domingo
en tanzania dejando al menos 19 personas
muertas tras caer en un lago mientras
intentaba aterrizar según las
autoridades el accidente se habría
producido por las adversas condiciones
climáticas
y hoy se cumplen 37 años de un hecho que
marcó la historia de Colombia la toma
del Palacio de Justicia por parte de la
entonces guerrillas del m-19 que ingresó
a las instalaciones y tomó como Rehenes
a magistrados y más personas
Muy buenas tardes y muy bienvenidos una
nueva emisión de noticias de Franz 24 en
español Gracias por acompañarnos soy
Santiago aristian y comenzamos con una
de las noticias que sin lugar a duda
marca la jornada de hoy primer día de la
Copa 27 hablamos por supuesto de la
Cumbre sobre el cambio climático de la
ONU Un año más la ciencia avisa sobre
las consecuencias de un mundo Cada vez
más cálido y Espera que la política tome
en cuenta estas advertencias Este día
inaugural de la Cumbre climática
coincide con la publicación de un
informe de la Organización meteorológica
Mundial que confirma que los últimos
ocho años han sido los más cálidos desde
que hay registros y también que las
concentraciones de dióxido de carbono y
metano en la atmósfera están en máximos
históricos con emisiones que no cesan el
resumen de esta primera jornada de la
Copa 27 con nuestra enviada especial
Egipto Marina Colorado
la inauguración de la cob 27 se hizo
esperar una hora y media pero lo hizo
con buenas noticias la inclusión en la
agenda oficial de la discusión de las
llamadas pérdidas y daños es decir cómo
pagar por los costos derivados de los
impactos que no se pueden evitar o que
ya han sucedido como consecuencia del
calentamiento global unos impactos que
sufren en su mayoría los países en
desarrollo que son los que menos han
contribuido al cambio climático el tema
que ha venido reclamando desde hace más
de 30 años los países menos
industrializados fue de hecho lo que
alargó las negociaciones previas a la
sesión inaugural y que causó el retraso
de la conferencia en sus discursos tanto
el presidente de la co26 el británico
alox arma como el que recibió el testigo
de las negociaciones de la con 27 el
egipcio
same sucre pidieron que el contexto
político y económico actual no desvíe la
atención de la crisis climática por su
parte el jefe de cambio climático de la
ONU recordó que mientras la guerra en
Ucrania y la inflación derivada de ellas
temporales el cambio climático está
empeorando aunque dice que sabemos cómo
frenarlo Y tenemos las herramientas
ahora solo falta implementarlas
precisamente la implementación es lo que
busca el presidente de la co27 en la
Cumbre de líderes que inicia mañana
lunes con más de 120 jefes de gobierno y
de estado Eso sí con grandes ausencias
como las de China Rusia o India el
presidente de Estados Unidos joeyden no
asistirá mañana ni el martes pero sí
vendrá a la co27 el 11 de noviembre una
vez haya pasado las elecciones de medio
término en su país
avanzamos ahora con información sobre la
guerra en Ucrania medios rusos
informaron que un bombardeo llevado a
cabo por las fuerzas de kiev causó daños
a La Represa hidroeléctrica que no vaya
Gogh ubicado en la región de gerson los
reportes indican que el ataque fue
perpetrado con misiles y más de
fabricación estadounidense según Rusia
cinco fueron interceptados pero el
último provocó los daños las autoridades
pero rusas persona asegura que las
fuerzas ucranianas concentran tanques de
Cara a una posible contra ofensiva Por
otra parte en la zona de saporiyamp un
ataque ruso dejó al menos una persona
muerta en la madrugada del domingo
y del otro lado en quiebras las
autoridades ya evalúan uno de los peores
escenarios posibles que implicaría tomar
una medida sin precedentes el alcalde de
la ciudad dijo que la urbe Ya se está
preparando para cortes totales de
energía calefacción y agua consecuencia
por supuesto de los daños que sufren la
infraestructura eléctrica del país
provocado por los bombardeos rusos un
escenario que requeriría evacuar a
millones de personas
vamos con más noticias vinculadas a la
guerra el grupo militar privado ruso
Wagner que se mantenía reservado hasta
ahora inauguró el viernes su primera
sede oficial y lo hizo en la ciudad de
San Petersburgo la organización asegura
defender los intereses de Rusia y
también su defensa militar pero a nivel
internacional ha sido objeto de todo
tipo de acusaciones principalmente de
crímenes de guerra en muchísimos países
centro del grupo militar Wagner se lee
en el cartel se trata de la nueva y
deslumbrante sede de lo que hasta hace
poco Era uno de los grupos paramilitares
rusos más ocultos del mundo en su
inauguración el viernes el centro de
varias plantas en San Petersburgo fue
anunciado como un espacio creativo para
las empresas patrióticas que quieren
Apoyar el sector de la defensa de Rusia
el edificio fue construidada
experiencias privadas y está preparado
para ofrecer espacio gratuito a los
blogueros diseñadores ingenieros y
creativos que tienen un objetivo y una
tarea hacer que nuestro hermoso país sea
aún mejor
pero detrás de esta reluciente fachada
Los mercenarios del grupo Wagner han
sido acusados de crímenes de guerra en
varios países de África y en Siria y
recientemente en Ucrania donde cada vez
se ha visto más involucrado los críticos
lo ven como una fuerza en la sombra del
kremlin utilizada para promover los
intereses rusos en el extranjero
proporcionando combatientes y asesores
el gobierno ruso siempre ha negado
cualquier vínculo Pero el mes pasado un
oligarca y Aliado de Vladimir Putin Y
precushin puso fin a años de rumores
cuando admitió que estaba detrás del
grupo no hubo rastro del multimillonario
en la inauguración del centro que al
parecer financió personalmente
es probablemente la única persona en
Rusia que ahora habla abiertamente con
retórica patriótica y no duda en decir
abiertamente que da su dinero personal a
la operación especial de Ucrania los
analistas afirman que el centro Wagner
se considera un paso más de pie goshen
para adoptar un papel más público en la
configuración de la política de defensa
de Rusia desde que se presentó como
fundador del grupo en este video de re
de prisioneros para la Guerra de Ucrania
ha criticado cada vez más abiertamente
la actuación de los generales rusos en
la guerra contra el país vecino
cambiamos de tema un avión de pasajeros
se estrelló este domingo en tanzania
dejando al menos 19 personas muertas
tras caer en el Lago Victoria cuando se
acercaba al aeropuerto debucobab según
las autoridades este accidente se había
producido por las adversas condiciones
climáticas Andrés triviño tiene los
detalles
tragedia aérea en África Oriental un
avión de pasajeros de la aerolínea
precision Air se estrelló en el Lago
Victoria en tanzania cuando se
aproximaba a su destino final las
autoridades informaron que activaron los
protocolos de emergencia de inmediato
nos lamentamos informar que el vuelo
pw494 operado en un avión atr48 viajaba
desde la ciudad de dares a la ama hacia
el aeropuerto de bucoba durante su
aproximación la aeronave se accidentó y
cayó sobre el Lago Victoria con 38
adultos un niño y cuatro tripulantes de
cabina el accidente ocurrió en la mañana
del domingo y minutos después la
aerolínea más grande de tanzania informó
que las personas rescatadas fueron
trasladadas para recibir atención médica
a un hospital de caguera Región donde
sucedió el accidente según el canal
Estatal radio televisión nacional de
tanzania el accidente habría sido
causado por las difíciles condiciones
climáticas registrando Fuertes lluvias y
vientos en el momento del accidente
cuando el avión estaba a unos 100 metros
de su destino se encontró con problemas
y mal tiempo estaba lloviendo y la
aeronave se hundió en el agua Todo está
bajo control
ya que se han desplegado todos los
equipos de rescate y seguridad para
ayudar hemos logrado salvar a un buen
número de personas
un equipo de precisión Air y la
autoridad de Aviación civil de tanzania
se desplazaron inmediatamente al lugar
de los hechos para investigar la causa
exacta del accidente
continuamos con noticia de América
Latina hoy se cumplen 37 años de un
hecho que marcó la historia de Colombia
hablamos de la toma del Palacio de
Justicia por parte de la entonces
guerrilla del m-19 que ingresó a las
instalaciones y tomó como Rehenes a
magistrados servidores judiciales y
también visitantes y luego la policía y
el ejército iniciaron un operativo de
retoma vamos a analizar este hecho
histórico de Colombia junto con el
historiador Germán Sánchez vaquero
Germán Muchísimas gracias por su
presencia 24 en español quisiera
preguntarle por supuesto para nuestra
audiencia internacional verdad qué
ocurrió aquel miércoles 6 de noviembre
de 1985 y que representa este hecho para
Colombia
buenas tardes y gracias por la
invitación Bueno pues nada
principalmente y la llamada toma y
retoma del Palacio de Justicia es uno de
los puntos más importantes de la
historia contemporánea en Colombia
principalmente porque fue el último gran
operativo militar
telem-19 o movimiento 19 de abril una
guerrilla ya extinta Y pues la cual tuvo
importante líderes como Antonio Navarro
Wolf Gustavo Petro o Carlos Pizarro León
Gómez básicamente
fue una acción Armada la cual tenía por
objetivo forzar al entonces presidente
de Colombia Belisario Betancourt acudir
al palacio de Justicia ya en manos del
m-19 a asistir a un juicio público
es claramente pues
podría ocasionar
pues
la condena tanto nacional como
internacional al gobierno de betancura
lo cual ocasionó que los militares
llevarán a cabo un proceso de retoma
sobre la acción emprendida por el m-19
pero en la cual se cometieron excesos
que dieron con la desaparición de muchos
de varios magistrados
civiles los cuales está demostrado en
vídeos en fotografías que lograron salir
con vida del operativo y posteriormente
aparecieron sus cuerpos realmente
sí no bueno perdón hablaba usted no de
esta retoma de todo lo que ocurrió aquel
día y vinculado a esto bueno el gobierno
colombiano Está avanzando de manera
formal no en posibles acuerdos de paz
con organizaciones ilegales Guerrilleras
como historiador no que nos enseñó esta
historia sobre lo ocurrido aquel día
sobre todo de Cara a estas posibles
negociaciones
bueno como un punto de vista personal y
todo lo que fue el proceso de paz con el
m-19 y también el proceso de paz con los
parques en el 2016
nos muestran que es necesario aceptar y
reconocer los excesos de cada uno de los
bandos todos conocemos los excesos de la
guerrilla de los movimientos sublevados
armados pero a nosotros como colombianos
y creo que nos cuesta mucho
aceptar los excesos de las fuerzas
armadas y hasta que eso no suceda no se
puede llevar a cabo un proceso de paz o
un proceso de desmovilización porque hay
que separar aprender a separar ese
concepto de paz y desmovilización
efectivo es importante reconocer los
excesos de todos Germán muchísimas
gracias y nos acaba el tiempo debo
despedirlo muchas gracias por su
presencia en France 24 avanzamos ahora
con más noticias y vamos a Estados
Unidos que se prepara para las
elecciones de medio término del próximo
8 de noviembre faltan tan solo dos días
y Pensilvania es uno de los estados que
podrían decidir el control del senado
pero donde muchos votantes y
trabajadores electorales tienen miedo
después de las amenazas que recibieron
tras el lento conteo de los resultados
en las elecciones presidenciales de 2020
veamos el informe
entramos en la oficina del comisionado
electoral de Pensilvania
desde aquí Omar savir promueve y asegura
la participación de los votantes Lo
mismo hizo los comicios presidenciales
del 2020 y por eso recibió estas
amenazas
en hablar
hace su trabajo con miedo
yo diría con más conciencia y con más
propósito siento que incluso si mi vida
se perdiera por el trabajo que estoy
haciendo merece la pena creo que la
democracia no tiene
precios
pero encontrar 8.500 trabajadores para
los más de 1700 centros de votación no
está siendo nada fácil porque hay miedo
los funcionarios insisten en que la
seguridad está garantizada
hay cosas que es mejor no hacer públicas
pero quiero asegurar que todo el mundo
estará seguro como siempre ha estado
entendemos que hay preocupa estamos al
tanto de eso y estamos trabajando en
ello
imposible que haya fallos en la boleta
Esta es nuestra boleta de prueba Estas
son las máquinas donde ya se está
votando de manera anticipada pero lo
mejor de estas máquinas es que tienes un
recibo de verificación
una garantía de que ninguna boleta se
pierde no seleccionaré ningún candidato
para quienes votan por correo los 18.000
buzones que hay en la ciudad están
controlados por cámaras de
videovigilancia como esta Pensilvania es
un estado clave para determinar el
control del senado y también la futura
agenda política del presidente Joe biden
es una de las pocas oportunidades que
tienen los demócratas de quitarles un
escaño a los republicanos pero aquí los
resultados están muy ajustados y la
participación en mayor o menor medida va
a ser decisiva por eso el candidato
republicano trata de ganar votos entre
los latinos pero su agenda electoral no
convence a votantes como Karen ponlo de
migración de que están con los de o y
todo eso los afroamericanos también
pueden decidir al ganador porque están
más indecisos que nunca
y así está siendo este comisionado
espera una de las mayores cifras de
participación que se han visto en los
últimos años
en breve regresamos con más noticias
sigan en francés 24
[Música]